hey not supposed to do that so a couple
days ago put out a video on how I made
an OpenGL base library and today I want
to kind of extend that base library
because I mentioned that it was very
much a work in progress and in fact it
just will be a work in progress for the
unforeseeable future as most software
projects are they're just gonna be
things that we discover along the way of
using this thing where we're gonna just
want to add stuff to it it's pretty
typical so don't expect this to be any
kind of finished product I keep saying
that every time but I just want you guys
to be on the same page as me regarding
what this is
so OpenGL core is kind of what I've
called it here it is on github there'll
be a link in the description below you
can access that is just github home
slash the channel slash OpenGL and
basically the purpose of this whole
library is just to make writing OpenGL
code really straightforward and really
easy without having to like download
some kind of wrapper or extension loader
or like a windowing system setting that
up
input events not about stuff you
basically just clone this library and
you're ready to type OpenGL code
straight away with very very minimal
set-up time and the whole purpose of
course for this was to enable me to kind
of teacher from jail going forward as
well as for yourselves as well if you
want to just kind of experiment with
OpenGL or play around with the test
something out without having to kind of
go through this kind of tedious setup
process every single time so the
additions that I've kind of made to this
since last time I've I've added some
commits just today I basically separated
the sandbox and examples as I mentioned
I would and there's just some other kind
of miscellaneous fixes that I've done as
well I want to specifically talk about
pre make in this video because what I've
done is I've kind of separated the one
pre make script that did everything
except for the dependencies into
multiple pre make scripts basically
every project opengl core examples
insert and sandbox that are inside this
repository and separating your premade
files into multiple files like that is
not the most straightforward thing to do
but it's really really powerful for the
future because it means that you can for
example generate multiple solution files
easily so let's take a look at what this
actually does how it's changed and then
we'll actually take a look at my
additions to the library as well so this
is the this is the root of the
repository this is what you get when you
clone it if we go into scripts and then
Wyn pre-made bat then you'll see that it
generates this OpenGL sandbox solution a
bunch of project files and also this
OpenGL examples solution so we actually
have two solution files being generated
from this premix script and the purpose
for this is if we go back a directory we
have examples and sand sandbox sandbox
as I mentioned is something that is
supposed to be this is where you dive in
and write your OpenGL code so for
example this is fresh after cloning the
repository and I've generated the
project files I can jump in here I can
open OpenGL sandbox and then sandbox
layer dot cpp which is the kind of main
file here and then it's got a bunch of
comments for where i can kind of do
things within this file without having
to even create any files or do anything
really so for example I've got my
initialization code here I've got my
update code here what I could do is just
immediately start typing in OpenGL code
so I could for example set the clear
color to like red and then in on update
I might just go ahead and clear the
color buffer then all I have to do is
run the program and you can see that
that's really it if I wanted to do more
which of course is likely I can just
dive in and do it I don't have to worry
about setting anything up and that's the
whole purpose of this library of course
there's a lot more you can actually do
this is just scratching the surface so
here we have our red clear color done
simple as that so this was the sandbox
project but then there's also another
project which is the examples project
and this is going to be like a library
of examples that we basically build up
over time so at the moment it's got a
very very basic example that just shows
what you can kind of do with the library
I extended it a little bit because I
wanted to test some things out so if we
take a look at this if we open up
example layer dot cpp you know this
creates like a vertex array it loads
some shaders we have some basic event
processing kind of shows you how you can
use the event system here so what this
does is what if the mouse button is
pressed the square color is change the
color of the square that is we can also
control this stuff through I am GUI so
if we launch this you'll see that we
have a little bit more of an example
we've actually got a square this uses
the camera system so I can kind of zoom
in and out and move it around just like
that if I click any mouse button and
hold it down you can see the color
changes to whatever this kind of
alternate color here is so I could
change the base color to like
or something like that and then the
alternate color to black for example and
if I hold the mouse button down changes
to black very very simple OpenGL example
but it shows you how you can kind of use
the OpenGL code to actually construct
the vert the vertices and everything
required for this actual square as well
as control the colors through I'm GUI
and then hook into the advanced system
to do anything really so with these true
projects in mind how do we split up pre
make to generate both of those things
well we have our base pre make 5 lua
script over here if I open this with vs
code we can read what this is all about
it's not particularly long it's about 70
lines of code what we have here is the
opengl sandbox project now workspace in
pre make of course is translated
directly to a visual studio solution so
we have this sandbox workspace which is
that sandbox solution we have some
configuration setup all the kind of
stuff you would expect include
directories is it just compiler include
directories for all of the different
dependencies and then what we do is when
it's time to actually include a project
so we do include these kind of
dependencies as standard include opengl
core means that we actually include the
pre make v dot lower file inside that
opengl core folder so it has its own lua
script which describes the actual
project properties so if we open up
urban GL core and then pre make $5
you'll see we have a very kind of simple
lua script here which is just the opengl
core project stand-alone and the benefit
of kind of separating this out into its
own file means that I can use that same
project multiple times because the
opengl sandbox solution needs to
reference this opengl core project so
does that opengl examples solution so
both of those solutions that both need
to reference that one project but I
don't want to rewrite the whole project
file or do anything weird like that I
just want to kind of reference the
existing one and the biggest secret of
doing that not that is a huge secret is
we basically use this include external
file so this is my opengl example
solution right the first time i do this
i just include it but once has been
included once i can reuse it by using
include external and what this will do
is kind of reference that project
without actually re running that entire
script because i don't want to run all
this lowest script i don't want to set
up the files again i don't want to set
up this whole OpenGL call project all I
want to do is include
again inside this workspace because I've
started a new workspace it's my OpenGL
examples workspace this should not be
doubled up like that I'd better fix that
I need to include that OpenGL core
project again so I can use include
external same with the dependencies
because they've already been included
once up here in kind of the first
sandbox workspace but then to include
them again I can just use include
external now you can see that OpenGL
examples itself and OpenGL sandbox
itself they're also separate little
files so if I go up a directory and I go
to OpenGL examples and I drag in that
pre make five little file that is that
kind of pre make five little file and
then back over here inside OpenGL
sandbox I have the same thing set up so
I can kind of set up a separate pre make
script for every single project I have
and then just reference them you know
for the first time with include and then
if they use more than once with include
external so it's nice and easy and it
definitely makes this whole thing a lot
more modular and a lot more simple so
this definitely simplifies a kind of
larger pre-made project where instead of
just having one massive script that does
everything and then in turn can only
really generate that one solution for me
by having separate premake files per
project I can reuse those projects for
multiple workspaces right so in this
case for multiple solutions because I
wanted that examples one week just dive
in a look at the examples but then I
also wanted the sandbox one where you
can just open it up and start typing in
your OpenGL code in like kind of a blank
file and that's pretty much it I don't
think there's much more I could really
say if you're still kind of confused by
this and definitely check out the
repository because that's what has these
pre-make files in it just give them a
read I'm sure it all makes sense you can
always Google like pre make five include
external or something like that if
you're not sure as to what a particular
keyword actually does but it is pretty
simple and and it's pretty powerful and
I love using pre make even even on
Windows making all the builds be a lot
more standardized meaning someone with
like different Windows SDK versions for
example can generate the right solution
files or if they're using different
versions of Visual Studio kind of makes
everything a lot more robust because
you're not relying on a single version
of Visual Studio and then having to
manually change anything like that it's
also really important for other
platforms like Mac
and Linux and we'll see that in the
future as we bring this library through
those platforms anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget to hit that like button
drop a comment below with your thoughts
or if you want to see something specific
and I will see you next time goodbye
[Music]